[Musik]
wir sprechen lieber moderne arbeiten
werden noch diese perspektiven täuschen
nicht über die tatsache hinweg dass es
noch immer menschen gibt die sich
verkaufen müssen um überleben zu können
ihnen selbst bei syrische regisseur sie
als calcium in seinem film ein denkmal
das talent der geschmack von zement
gewann beim dokumentarfilmfestival
visions du réel in mir der film zeigt
syrische arbeiter die im libanon tag für
tag läufer errichten zement aufschichten
während in ihrer heimat syrien tag für
tag die häuser zerstört werden
wer oder was im lärm der baustelle jedem
umschreibt sich der bau lift nach oben
bringt sie syrische wanderarbeiter in
schwindelerregende höhen zukünftiger
wolkenkratzer geflohen sind die männer
aus dem kriegsgebeutelten syrien in
vermeintliche freiheit
sie bauen den libanon auf jenes land das
vor 25 jahren komplett darniederlag der
sturz vom bürgerkrieg
der syrische regisseur riad kalzium lebt
seit zwei jahren in berlin
ein flüchtling er setzt in seinem film
zeigt er krieg auf einem ungewöhnlichen
blickwinkel man auf youtube findet man
millionen von bildern die menschen jeden
tag wie sie unter den bombardierungen
gegen diese bilder könnten
ich wollte eine andere geschichte
erzählen andere bilder zeigen sagt des
aufbaus hat dabei für mich wichtiger als
der akte zerstören oder des tötens in
ruhigen langen einstellungen zeigt
kalzium das heutige beirut ansichten
einer befriedeten stadt in der die
kriegs haben allmählich verschwinden an
deren genesung aber nicht alle teilhaben
dürfen
die wollen ja aber da stehen jeden
morgen vor der kulisse von beirut
aber sie dürfen nicht in die stadt gehen
so wird diese kulisse irgendwann zu
einer wand tapete einer wunderschönen
und so sollte es aussehen
alles ist so plakativ der ozean
die fräse mehr man sie bereiteten den
bauarbeitern ara ist es verboten nach
feierabend die baustelle zu verlassen
sie hausen in den untergeschossen in
menschenfeindlicher umgebung eine wahl
haben wir nicht verloren wirken sie und
bleiben stunden im film
sie haben angst vor dem was sie wollen
nicht über politik spricht und sie
dürfen auch nicht darüber sprechen wie
sie leben in diesem loch
sie haben angst vor dem besitzer nichts
anderes sieht so frieden aus bis nach
schauen die arbeiter bilder vom krieg in
syrien von ihren häusern
die zerfetzt werden alles jurack in den
geschmack ihrer häuser wenn sie zerstört
werden
die von beton bedeckt werden und
schmecken die menschen der film gipfelt
in einer parallelmontage wie eine
brutale erkenntnis bringt da verstörung
ihr aufbau dort krieg hier frische
demenz krieg
aufbau krieg
der konsum in homs geboren hat im
ehemaligen stalingrad studiert in beirut
als flüchtling gelegt und jetzt berlin
städte die allesamt das krieg zerstört
und danach wieder aufgebaut wird
[Musik]
unaufhörlich geht es immer so weiter und
dazwischen namenlose arbeiter die sie
tief ausgleich schafften